what if that means this means hi in
horses oh yeah hey Cesar how you doing
good good you over here so we can help
this lady over here all right I brought
my helpers yeah what's your name that's
junior and deaths daddy thank you I've
been wanting to say this for a long time
how can we help you well I love horses
and I love dogs and the combination I
have two dogs that when they get around
horses they are aggressive they bark
they jump and if the horse tries to buck
the children get very scared
they like horses and we don't want to
discourage that we want them to continue
you know loving to ride without the dogs
have a bit of horse well they've been on
lead to my best of my ability they
haven't been a horse yet but given the
opportunity they might have two I have
two
we're in those two guys which one is the
most intense the most intense is hobo
hobo is the little one and hope that's
the one who's goes in the brothel yeah
so Chloe assist pack leader I'd like to
think we are but I what if a dog is
attacking somebody or chasing you or not
otherwise it would be like this you know
sniffing around and this when you're the
pack leader because they're doing
exactly what you want them to do prey is
right there doesn't mean they have to
get near them tell me about the horse
now cupcake is one of our therapy horses
and we tend to use older horses for the
therapy oldest e22 all right when we
teach a student will have to side
workers walkers and a leader pardon my
New York accent what happens is is that
cupcake will try to kick one of the side
walkers you see a confident horse I
would say yes yeah so usually confidence
leads to dominance
she'd like to move her feet a lot yes
and does she have a low medium or high
spirit is she the kind of horse that
just go go go like all the time so she's
medium maybe so maybe this is an
assertiveness issue and one of the
things I've always been teaching for
years is is that there's two kinds of
people it tends to be the carrot person
who's gonna be really really nice and
just go there the other extreme is the
stick person and in the middle of the
road is a carrot stick person do you
have it today I have my orange carrot
stick with me today well it reminds us
to be the extreme middle of the road and
I got my magic leash so drink I'm
through for me to work with this guy if
I just may say four people how people
treat dogs and how people treat horses
[Laughter]